- 90% of the clothes
they're not gonna fit.
- My small frame is not
what stores think of.
- Do you have a size 15?
And they'll be like no.
Scaring away normal customers.
- Dialing on what actually fits you
is more important than
just getting something
that gives you the look.
- I actually try my best to go to stores
that have extra smalls available
because those usually fit me very well.
I think I feel the most conscience
of myself at formal events
because formal events involve blazers.
Especialy shoulders don't
quite sit right on my body
and anything that goes past my waist
will make me look shorter
than I already am.
- The one physical characteristic
that people will come up to you
and just like throw in
your face about you.
Boy, are you tall!
Most stores don't have anything for me
so my go to clothing is usually
like solid colored t shirts.
Like I need a very long t shirt
but that usually makes it wider.
I just sort of gave up.
- As a bigger dude
I'm totally comfortable
with the size of my body
but you don't want to look unflattering.
Plain and simple.
Typically I wear like
my pants a little higher
just to kind of flatten out the stomach
and if I can't find clothes
that don't look good on me
then it makes me really
not want to go shopping.
I think this is going to be super fun.
I'm gonna get mansformed today.
- What would you consider
an area of opportunity
in your wardrobe?
- Opportunity.
There's a lot of real estate.
- I wanna accentuate the
rights areas of my torso.
- For me, part of looking sharp
is to have form fitting stuff.
- One of my concerns
when I am wearing tighter fitting clothing
is mobility.
- I don't even wear these
shoes all that often
cause they've got laces.
Like my feet are so far away from my head.
- You actually have a greater closet
if you remove things that are either
eye sores that you
don't gravitate towards,
things that are ill-fitting,
or things that are
pretty old and tattered.
- Yeah.
These jeans have a big hole in them.
- We all have different body shapes.
And I wanted to let the guys know today
is that what you feel is your insecurity
is usually your strength.
(techno music)
Let's see your new look.
- OK.
Oh, yeah!
Oh my god.
I love it.
- You've noticed I've clipped
a few of the areas to show you that
you should generally go for this fit.
You take the clips out here
and the only alteration you actually need
is a hem.
The most basic alteration
that you can get either from a tailor
or drycleaners.
A hem is probably about five to ten bucks.
- Tailoring is an option
and I think a lot of us
especially guys they forget that.
I'm feeling myself.
This is so nice.
(rock music)
- Oh my god.
(laughs)
Wow.
I have never seen myself look
like this before in my life.
- Garret didn't know his sizes.
And I wanted to help him feel
like he knows the things that fit him
and how to be assertive
when going shopping.
- As easy as understanding
your measurements
and like what's going to work for you.
That's the hurdle that I cleared today.
Oh my god.
I'm going to spend so much money
going shopping this weekend.
(electronic music)
- Alright, turn around.
- Ho, ho, ho.
This is what I'm talking about.
- His body type, as many others,
needs to be seen first as the shape
that he'd like to see.
Thinking about your ensemble
as a silhouette then you are able to see
the broader picture.
- First thing you see
is that person's shape
and then start filling in the pieces,
adding accents.
- It is a softer shoulder jacket.
- So I can actually
- Move around
- Add a little bit more
- in it.
- movement.
- I'm still just looking at myself like
is that me?
- So for all the big dudes
that think that they can't have style
look at this?
- I know that fear of being tall
and not thinking anything's
gonna be for you.
Just takes finding a
couple of examples of it
to then be able to know
what you're looking for.
- When you're a smaller guy
it's not about dressing taller
it's about just dressing
better for yourself.
- What you choose should be for you
and not for whatever's trending.
First your personality, clothes second.
- You can go out and find clothing that
a fits you, b looks good,
c is comfortable,
and d makes you look confident as hell.